j'ai l'honneur de vous présenter la
locution préenregistrés de son
excellence monsieur mahmoud abbas
président de l'état 1 2 la palestine à
l'occasion du débat général de la 75e
session de l'assemblée générale je vous
remercie
excellence monsieur volkan de spire
président de l'assemblée générale
excellence monsieur antonio gutiérrez
secrétaire général des nations unies
mesdames et messieurs les représentants
que la paix soit sur vous lorsque j'ai
préparé mon discours je me suis demandé
ce que je pouvais ajouter à tout ce que
j'ai déjà dit à maintes reprises que
pourrais-je dire de plus qu'en de
souffrance de mon peuple de la misère
qu'ils vivent au quotidien alors que le
monde reste les bras croisés et que
leurs aspirations légitimes ne sont
toujours pas exaucés des aspirations à
vivre dans la liberté l'indépendance la
dignité comme le reste du monde
mesdames et messieurs
combien de temps encore avant qu'une
solution juste ne soit trouvée à la
question palestinienne
une solution garantie par le droit
international
combien de temps encore est ce que le
peuple palestinien va continuer
d'agoniser sous le joug de l'occupation
israélienne
combien de temps encore avant qu'une
solution juste ne soit trouvée vis-à-vis
du statut de millions de réfugiés
palestiniens
une solution conforme aux résolutions
pertinentes des nations unies adoptée il
ya 70 ans
mesdames et messieurs le peuple
palestinien vit dans sa terre natale la
palestine la terre de leurs pères et
grands-pères depuis 6000 ans le peuple
palestinien restera sur ce territoire et
résistera à l'occupation à l'agression
et à la trahison
jusqu'à ce qu'il puisse jouir de ses
droits
malgré les difficultés et malgré le
blocus injuste qui a pour objectif de
leur faire du mal nous ne courberont pas
l'échiné
nous ne nous rendrons pas nous ne ferons
aucun compromis
et nous vaincrons
mesdames et messieurs nous avons accepté
la médiation internationale malgré
l'injustice historique que nous
subissons depuis 1917
cette médiation ne nous a rien apporté
d'autre que les territoires qui ont été
occupés en 1967
néanmoins israël la puissance occupante
avec l'appui du gouvernement américain
actuel a décidé de faire fi de cette
médiation internationale pour favoriser
la prétendue affaire du siècle
au titre de cette affaire de ce contrat
israël a pour intention d'annexer 33%
des territoires de l'état de la
palestine ainsi que jérusalem est
occupée y compris la mosquée al aqsa et
l'église du saint sépulcre nous tout
comme le monde entier avons rejeté ces
plans qui vont à l'encontre de toutes
les résolutions internationales ayant
reconnu l'état de la palestine en 2012
comme étant un membre de la communauté
internationale nous nous sommes toujours
exprimé en faveur d'une paix globale
juste et pérenne
nous avons accepté toutes les
initiatives proposées
moi personnellement j'ai consacré ma vie
entière à la cause de la paix et ce
depuis 1988
en passant par la conférence de madrid
et par les accords d'oslo en 1993
je continue de consacrer ma vie à la
peine à ce jour encore nous nous sommes
engagés en faveur de l'initiative de
paix arabe garantissant sécurité paix et
coexistence après la cessation de
l'occupation si nous l'avons fait c'est
pour parvenir à la paix et café israël
en échange israël est revenu sur tous
les accords qu'elle avait passé et à
fouler aux pieds la solution à deux
états de par ses actes d'agression
israël a tué à arrêter a démoli des
maisons et à étouffer notre économie
israël a cherché à systématiquement
modifier le caractère et l'identité de
jérusalem occupée et israël un profane
et c'est sites saints chrétiens et
musulmans
plus particulièrement la mosquée al aqsa
israël a poursuivi l'élargissement de
ses colonies sur nos territoires et a
ignoré l'initiative de paix arabe et de
par ses actions unilatérales et
irresponsable israël est en train de
détruire la dernière chance qui nous
reste de parvenir à la paix pour
couronner le tout israël les émirats
arabes unis et bahreïn viennent tout
juste de signer des accords de
normalisation qui vont à l'encontre de
l'initiative de paix arabe et des
principes d'une solution juste et
pérenne au titre du droit international
l'organisation de libération de la
palestine n'a jamais demandé à quiconque
de s'exprimer ou de négocier
du peuple palestinien la seule façon de
parvenir à une paix globale juste et
pérenne dans notre région et de cesser
l'occupation et de garantir
l'indépendance de l'état de la palestine
le long des frontières de 1967 avec
jérusalem est pour capitale
[Musique]
à cet égard j'appelle le secrétaire
général des nations unies a entamé les
préparatifs aux côtés du quatuor et du
conseil de sécurité en vue d'une
conférence internationale qui aurait
lieu au début de l'année prochaine et
réunir est toutes les parties pertinents
cette conférence devrait être à même de
lancer un véritable processus de paix en
s'appuyant sur le droit international et
sur les mandats pertinents son objectif
devrait être de faire cesser
l'occupation d'accorder au peuple
palestinien sa liberté et son
indépendance dans son état le long des
frontières de 1967 avec jérusalem est
pour capitale et son objectif devrait
également être de régler toutes les
questions relatives au statut final
notamment la question des réfugiés
conformément à la résolution 193 194 se
corrige l'internet
mesdames et messieurs il est un leurre
que penser que le peuple palestinien
pourrait un jour accepter l'occupation
ou plier sous la pression et les diktats
c'est un leurre de penser que le peuple
palestinien pourrait être écarté cette
cause est la nôtre
vous devriez tous bien savoir qu'il ne
saurait y avoir de paix de sécurité de
stabilité ou de coexistence dans notre
région sans que l'occupation ne cesse et
sans que l'on trouve une solution juste
et globale à la question palestinienne
c'est cette question qui se trouve au
coeur du conflit
mesdames et messieurs les palestiniens
incarne une nation pleine de vie et
créative
les palestiniens sont épris de paix et
de liberté
malgré l'occupation les palestiniens
sont parvenus à ériger une société
active et moderne faisant fond sur la
démocratie et l'état de droit
ils ont réussi à préserver leur identité
nationale
malgré leurs divergences politiques et
intellectuelles contre toute attente
nous nous préparons à tenir
des élections législatives et
présidentielles auxquelles participeront
tous les partis politiques
nous continuerons de vivre
nous continuerons d'espérer nous
resterons engagés en faveur de notre
unité nationale et de notre démocratie
malgré toutes les tentatives de nier
notre existence nous lutterons tant que
nous n'auront pas regagné la place qui
nous revient parmi le concert des
nations et nous ferons l'exercice de
tous nos droits au titre du droit
international notamment notre droit à
résister face à l'occupation
nous continuerons d'ériger nos
institutions étatiques sur la base de
l'état de droit et nous continuerons de
combattre le terrorisme international
tout comme nous le faisons depuis des
années nous resterons attachés à la paix
à la justice et à la dignité humaine et
national
quelles que soient les circonstances en
conclusion je tiens à rendre hommage au
grand peuple palestinien qui lutte pour
sa liberté et son indépendance
je rends hommage à ceux qui ont été tués
ou blessés à leurs proches à jérusalem
et à ses citoyens inébranlable je rends
hommage à ceux d'entre nous qui vivent
dans la bande de gaza assiégée et dans
des camps de réfugiés de par le monde et
je rends également hommage à tous les
pays
nation organisation qui nous ont
défendus et ont défendu nos droits que
la paix et les bénédictions divines soit
sur vous
on bien pour les jeunes hommes au nom de
l'assemblée générale je remercie le
président de l'état de palestine de la
déclaration qui vient de faire je
deviens présent la parole en europe